this morning in Iranian news agency
quotes a senior commander of its
Revolutionary Guards vowing further
revenge and the general chosen to
replace kasym Kasim rather Soleimani
said this morning that he too will
follow in the same path
Elizabeth Palmer's in Tehran with more
on this story well is it but that
certainly sounds very ominous but what
does that mean exactly
good morning well he's saying that the
goal hasn't changed that Iranian forces
will fight on - sooner or later make
American troops leave the region but the
headline here in Tehran in the immediate
term is that the American military is
not planning another strike in the first
real snowfall of the winter tehrany is
going about their business we're feeling
safer were you afraid that there was
going to be a war Carleen like millions
here listened to president Trump's
speech very closely were you relieved
when he said there would not be another
American attack yes I sleep very well
the fact that we have this great
military and equipment however does not
mean we have to use it we do not want to
use it that padarthas on Iranian TV
America's decision not to strike back
was framed as a climbed down by the US
and a win for Iran's Revolutionary
Guards who showcased their missile
arsenal one senior commander promised
that Iran would take harsher revenge
soon the killing of Qasem Soleimani
brought millions into the streets and
scenes like these in a show of unity but
the morning masses don't tell the whole
story just a few weeks ago thousands of
demonstrators showed their fury and
frustration with the government they
criticized for its corruption
and ineptitude but the mood has changed
completely and those voices of dissent
have fallen silent at least for now
Tony Elizabeth Palmer forests in Tehran
thank you very much
you